john
[Música]
oi gente
obrigada pelos aplausos eu só atacar
aberta diretor e coreógrafo da companhia
e recife momento final que vocês
registraram aqui talvez seja um pouco do
da sensação de satisfação de quando a
gente encontra o nosso lugar se é que a
gente já encontrou vai encontrar e o que
a gente acredita que esse lugar é
mutável
eu também me desconectei e fui procurar
ajuda e eu encontrei então uma teoria
que se chama abordagem sistêmica
pedagogia sistêmica que foi desenvolvida
pelo filósofo teólogo psicoterapeuta
alemão bert religuem e ele estudou pelo
mundo todo por muito tempo o
comportamento familiar e ele identificou
que todas as famílias independente de
credo de raça de lugar de origem se
comportam iguais e então ele identificou
que existem leis ocultas assim como a
lei das leis da física que atuam sobre
as nossas vidas sem o nosso conhecimento
e sem o nosso consentimento que seriam
as leis pertencimento equilíbrio e
hierarquia ou ordem o pertencimento uma
necessidade primordial do ser humano a
gente precisa pertencer fazer parte o
equilíbrio ele acredita que o sucesso
das relações está baseada na proporção
igual entre dar e receber que a única
relação que pode haver desequilíbrio
entre pais e filhos onde os pais dão
mais do que os filhos e por último a lei
da ordem ou hierarquia sobre honrar quem
veio primeiro hoje aqui a gente falou de
ancestralidade valor de energia valor de
origem falou de pertencimento se
conectar e desconectar e eu acredito que
as pessoas que estão vivenciando um
mesmo momento elas se conectam e existem
várias pessoas passando pela mesma coisa
pensando da mesma
em vários lugares do mundo ao mesmo
tempo eu estava com necessidade de
ocupar um lugar que eu não sabia se era
aquele que estavam se era um novo e o
que sabia fazer a dança e quando vi que
a pertencer reequilibrar kia e estavam
baseados no movimento do ser humano
aquilo ali resultou em dança e resolvi
perguntar pra mim a companhia em que
momento eles estavam e coincidentemente
todo mundo tava tentando ocupar o seu
lugar descobriu seu lugar e foi então
que surgiu esse espetáculo é e se
baseando nas constelações familiares
também estudada por robert rennie e
nessas três leis ocultas do amor e se
vocês quiserem conhecer um pouquinho
mais
este foi só um trechinho o espetáculo de
uma hora ocupando o meu lugar da
companhia com a cabeça ou das
constelações familiares e da abordagem
sistêmica
vocês podem entrar então nosso site com
a cabeça pontocom espero que tenham
gostado e a gente faz um convite à dança
contemporânea também sempre que este
gente puder ii
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]